Cracked iPhone screens may soon become a thing of the past.
Apple has filed a patent for a series of components...
...that can detect your iPhone's orientation when it's falling midair,...
...and change its center of mass...
...to ensure your screen doesn't shatter when the phone hits the ground.
It could, for example, rotate the phone on its back every time.
After you drop your phone and it's in free fall,...
...gyroscopes, image sensors and accelerometers...
...would calculate how fast your phone is falling,...
...how far it is from the ground and other reference points.
Hopelessly clumsy people worldwide will be overjoyed if Apple implements the technology,...
...because they know firsthand that the cost of fixing a broken iPhone screen...
...can be as much as the phone itself.